all right welcome back everybody okay so
I really enjoyed the last lecture I
always like getting really good
questions this time I'm going to try to
get through more than two pages of my
lecture notes so what I want to tell you
today is kind of continuing this theme
of analyzing ordinary differential
equations okay in the last few lectures
we've been looking at linear systems X
dot equals a matrix a times X and we've
been thinking about what the general
solution of this would look like in
terms of eigen vectors and eigen values
of a and we've characterized about half
of the cases okay so we're going to
characterize the other half of the cases
of two by two a matrices today but
before we do that I want to tell you
about nonlinear systems so most of us in
our research are not going to have
linear differential equations right
we're going to have nonlinear ode e's or
PDE s for real physical systems okay
there's going to be nonlinear terms all
kinds of nasty stuff but what I'm going
to show you right now is how under some
pretty general conditions we can
approximate nonlinear systems by linear
OD es in a vicinity of fixed points
where the dynamics equals zero okay so
how many of you have seen linearization
of nonlinear dynamics before how many of
you have nots okay good so we're
starting to get into some new stuff okay
so we're going to linearize non-linear
dynamics and we're going to do this near
a fixed point okay so let's say that in
general I have some X dot equals some
function of X so instead of just a
matrix a times X this might be x squared
or X cubed or X plus sine X right
something nasty so in the homework
the pendulum example you have something
like you know theta double dot equals
minus G over L sine theta so for any of
you who didn't like doing all the
partial derivatives this is what you
should get
for the fifth problem on the homework
this is a nonlinear differential
equation right sine of theta is a
nonlinear function okay so for this you
know for now you can just think of X and
f as being scalars by just one value X
not a vector but everything I'm going to
write down is going to be completely
general for vector X and a vector of
functions f1 f2 f3 and so on okay so I'm
going to define a fixed point X bar this
is a fixed point if f of X bar equals
zero okay this makes sense right the
rate of change of my variable is equal
to the sum function of my variable if
that function is equal to zero then my
rate of change of X is zero my X bar
stays put it's a fixed point okay pretty
simple so X bar is a fixed point if the
dynamics F so I call F the dynamics it's
how my X changes in time if that
dynamics is zero at X bar okay so for X
near X bar so in some neighborhood of
this fixed point X bar so let's say that
means that Delta x equals x minus x bar
is small so for some small Delta X
neighborhood around my fixed point I can
write these dynamics as an approximately
linear od I can approximate the dynamics
near my fixed point by a linear OTE okay
and I'm going to do that right now so
we're going to write down X dot and X
dot equals f of X but what we're going
to do is Taylor expand our dynamics f of
X about the base point X bar okay we're
just going to Taylor expand and this is
in the third lecture notes so lecture 3
we have this exact formula I'm going to
write
for this Taylor expansion of X about
some other point X bar so this is equal
to f of X bar plus what plus the
derivative of F with respect to X
evaluated at what point X bar okay I'm
going to write this derivative a little
bit differently than before I'm going to
write big D of F with respect to X this
expression is going to be this is just
the derivative of F with respect to X
this is f Prime but this will also this
is more general if F is a vector
functions and X is a vector of values
this is going to be a matrix of partial
derivatives I'll show you what that is
in a minute but for now this is just the
first derivative of F with respect to X
evaluated at X bar times my difference
from X bar X minus X bar plus what's the
next term okay 1 over 2 factorial second
derivative d squared FD x squared
evaluated at X bar times X minus X bar
squared this again just the second
derivative of F with respect to X I'm
just using a new notation plus 1 over 3
factorial d cubed F DX cubed x minus X
bar cubed plus dot dot I just realized
in my lecture notes I dropped I forgot
the factorial so remember there's always
factorials on these Taylor series okay
so what are some simplifications I can
make to this expression right away if
Delta X is small
yes so basically all of this stuff is
small for Delta X small right this is
just Delta X squared Delta X cubed if
Delta X is like point O one this is
0.0001 and this is 0.0001 real real
small okay what about this term f of X
bar it's zero right this is my fixed
points so I can make a pretty decent
approximation for small Delta X that my
dynamics near the fixed point is just
this first derivative times Delta X okay
so I'm going to write that down so I'm
going to write down the derivative in
terms of this Delta X variable so X dot
minus X bar dot what's X bar dot zero
it's a fixed point it's not moving so
this is equal to D DT of Delta X okay so
my Delta X variable my difference from
my fixed point it's rate of change is
just equal to X dot and X dot is
approximately equal to this term here so
it's approximately equal to DF DX
evaluated at my fixed point times Delta
X super-important okay
okay so questions about what we did here
before I go on to do an example okay we
have a fixed point where our dynamics
are zero in a neighborhood of that fixed
point so where X minus X bar is small so
in a small neighborhood of X bar then
the first term in the Taylor series is
zero all of the higher order terms are
nearly zero and this is the dominant
term in the Taylor series and so I can
say that the rate of change of my kind
of distance from this fixed point is
equal to this first derivative times
that distance okay it's a linear
equation in Delta X if you want to think
about it this way you could say that
we're kind of shifting our origin to the
X bar fixed points and this Delta X is
our new variable about that fixed point
so we're looking at the dynamics near
this fixed point okay now what's kind of
cool is that this expression is totally
general I can have this for a vector
valued function with a vector input X
and all of these terms still make sense
so I'm going to give you an example of
what these look like for kind of a
generic multivariable function okay so
let's do example
okay so if I have some vector function
of some vector X maybe this has you know
two components something like that I'm
going to do this example where it's F 1
of X 1 X 2 F 2 of X 1 X 2 okay
now the matrix derivative of F with
respect to my vector X is equal to how
many of you know how to take this this
kind of big derivative big capital D
derivative okay it's really
straightforward and simple okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to get
a matrix of partial derivatives the
first term is going to be the partial of
F 1 with respect to X 1 I'm going to
take the partial of my first row with
respect to my X 1 then I'm going to take
the partial of my first row with respect
to my X 2 then take the partial of my
second row with respect to X 1 and the
partial of my second row with respect to
X 2 this looks nasty but it's actually
pretty simple right these partial
derivatives are usually easy to do and I
get this matrix of first derivatives in
each of my variables X 1 and X 2 if you
ever want to remember what order like
the F ones and the x ones going the way
I think about this is I'm about to
multiply this by a delta X and so that's
going to be like Delta X 1 Delta X 2 and
so I better cancel out these Delta X 1
and Delta X 2's and the first row is
first derivatives of my first row the
second row are derivatives of my second
row that's how I remember where the f1
and f2 s go ok good
so let's do a real example so let's say
that this thing equals x1 minus x1
squared + x1 plus x2
okay so first things first let's just
take the big derivative the first
derivative of this function with respect
to our variable X okay so DF DX is going
to equal
okay what's the partial derivative of my
first row with respect to X 1 1 minus 2
X 1 ok what's the partial of my first
row with respect to X 2 0 there's no
excuse
okay partial of my second row with
respect to X 1 partial of my second row
with respect to X 2 1 ok so this is my
first derivative matrix okay so going
back to this equation here we start to
see that this first derivative is a
matrix which is good so it's starting to
look like X dot equals a times X it's
not exactly there yet because this
matrix is nasty and it might have like
you know if this was an X 1 cubed then I
would have had a 3 X 1 squared it would
have been nonlinear right the terms of
this matrix could be nonlinear functions
it's fine okay so the general procedure
to solve a system like this I just made
this one up in my office this morning is
we first look for the fixed points we
look for when this function is equal to
0 okay so when does this function equal
0
okay so just looking at the first row
one can that first row be 0 X 1 equals 0
or X 1 equals 1 okay if X 1 is 0 what is
X 2 f 2 B 0 and if X 1 is 1 what is that
you have to be negative 1 okay so these
are my two fixed points these are my X
bars 0 0 & 1 negative 1 so what we're
going to do is look at this derivative
matrix and I'm going to evaluate it at
my first fixed point and I'll get 1 a
matrix I'm going to evaluate it at my
second fixed point and I'll get another
a matrix so there are different linear
dynamics around each of these two fixed
points okay okay so let's think about it
so around X bar equals 0 0 we have an
equation DDT of you know Delta X 1 Delta
X 2 equals this matrix derivative
evaluated at my fixed point it equals DF
DX at X bar times Delta X 1 Delta X 2 ok
so if I just plug in my fixed point 0 0
into this matrix what do I get right
well I plug in a 0 for X 1 and X 2 and I
get 1 0 1 1 okay so what this says is
that if we're in a near vicinity of the
point 0 0 this nonlinear nasty
differential equation looks linear and
the the linear dynamics around that
fixed point are given by this a matrix
times my Delta X vector ok questions
about what we're doing here any
questions at all
okay how many of you think this makes
some sense okay how many of you are a
little lost right now it's okay if
you're a little lost right now
okay so luckily we have another fixed
point so we'll try this on the other
fixed point and see if we this makes
more sense okay so we do the exact same
thing about our second fixed points
right we have these two fixed points and
we're going to look at what the dynamics
look like in a small neighborhood around
these two fixed points so around our
second fixed point 1-1 we get the same
thing we get D DT of Delta X 1 Delta X 2
equals some matrix times Delta X 1 Delta
X 2 and I get this matrix by plugging my
fixed point in to my first derivative of
F so if I plug in 1 for X 1 I get minus
1 0 1 1 okay good
this is called the Jacobian df/dx is
called the Jacobian or the first
derivative ok good so I'm going to draw
a little sketch now so what does this
look like remember we like to think
geometrically everyone likes pictures X
2 X 1 ok so where are my two fixed
points one of them is at the origin
right and the other one is at plus 1
minus 1 so I have a fixed point here and
a fixed point here I don't know what
happens anywhere else but I know that in
some small region around this fixed
point the dynamics are going to look
like this and I know that in some small
region around this fixed point the
dynamics are going to look like this ok
so what
so how do we solve a linear system how
do we tell what this linear system and
this linear system are going to do yeah
we look at the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors okay so what are the
eigenvalues of this matrix it's really
easy to find the eigenvalues of a lower
or upper triangular matrix okay
because if I take this matrix minus
lambda I and I take its determinant I
get a product of all of the diagonal
elements minus 0 so I get lambda 1 - I
get lambda minus 1 times lambda minus 1
equals 0 and lambda equals 1 so lambda
equals 1 are my eigenvalues for this and
for this one lambda equals plus and
minus 1 okay so what does it look like
if lambda is plus or minus 1 a saddle
point okay so this fixed point here I
don't know what orientation the saddle
point is going to be I'd have to compute
the eigenvectors to figure that out but
it's probably going to be some kind of a
saddle point looking thing and what does
it look like if both of my eigenvalues
are positive
it's just unstable source in all
directions so this is kind of
everything's moving away from this point
and this point it's moving away in some
directions and it's moving in in other
directions and I could figure out what
the orientation of these these
directions are by looking at the
eigenvectors of both of these matrices
okay so I don't know what happens
between here probably something super
interesting like I bet oh it's hard to
say I don't know exactly what's going to
happen here there are other tools we're
going to talk about later to figure out
what happens in the middle and way out
here but at least I know that if I'm
near one of these fixed points I know
what the dynamics look like okay so this
is similar for the pendulum
okay any questions about this example
before I move on yeah
okay yeah while a long-term like
stability of Clara okay so so the
long-term stability of linearization is
interesting the idea this is a very good
question
and that's something I wasn't sure if I
was going to talk about because it's a
little bit complicated but it's really
really a good question okay so I have a
complex plane where all of my eigen
values have to live right all of my lamb
does for any system I can ever write
down are going to live in this complex
plane I might have plus and minus I I
might have plus and minus one I can have
any eigen values right and let's say I
have these three eigen values so I don't
know if any of you can't see then it's
probably on the board but let's buy of
these three eigen values then anything
in the left half plane with a negative
real part is stable so everything here
is stable any eigen values on the right
are unstable and what we're going to do
for the next example today is we're
going to show that if I have I can
values exactly on the imaginary axis
then it's kind of neutrally stable the
fixed point doesn't it's not a sink not
everything goes into the fixed point
it's not a source not everything goes
out but things just kind of rotate
around this fixed point forever and they
keep kind of the same radius so it's
neutrally stable it's not really that
stable it's not unstable okay so your
question is what happens for long time
stability of these fixed points in a
nonlinear system okay so the way we can
think about it I I wrote down my Taylor
series expansion and I kind of just
brushed all of the higher-order terms
under the rug but really these are
perturbing my linear dynamics they're
changing the shape near this fixed point
of where the vector field you know where
all the arrows and all the vectors look
but if my Delta X is
all enough SuperDuper small then I can
bound a region around each of these
eigenvalues where my new eigenvalues in
this nonlinear system will be okay so if
I'm in a tiny enough neighborhood of
this fixed point my eigenvalues are
going to be pretty darn close to 1 1 and
if I'm in a tiny enough neighborhood of
this fixed point my eigenvalues are
going to be pretty close to plus or
minus 1 so if I draw a really small kind
of epsilon ball around the the points
that are stable here if I draw the ball
small enough they're still stable even
with the additional nonlinear terms
these are still stable forever
same thing with my unstable points even
if I add this non-linearity if I'm in a
small enough region around this fixed
point it's still going to be unstable
forever now the points on the imaginary
axis are the interesting ones because my
non-linearity means I have this small
ball of uncertainty around that
eigenvalue which means it could be a
little bit in the positive half or a
little bit in the negative half so if I
take a system that is a center which is
just kind of rotating around with these
eigenvalues and I add a non-linearity it
could actually make it stable or make it
unstable so these are really dangerous
points where if we write down the linear
dynamics we might think it's stable but
when we add even the tiniest
non-linearity it can destabilize complex
conjugate pairs and eigen values so
that's a great question because it
segues directly into the next example
which is when I have complex conjugate
pairs of eigenvalues so thank you okay
so I wanted to show you how to linearize
a system because this is on the homework
okay so you're going to have an equation
like this you're going to write down
something like theta equals Omega Omega
equals minus G over L sine of theta and
then you're going to do something very
similar to what we just did you're going
to find the fixed point
you're going to linearize about the
fixpoints and you're going to assess the
stability okay okay I want to do one
other example of linearization before I
move on and something to note right this
Jacobian of F is a matrix the second
derivative is like instead of a matrix
it's like a cube of values I have to
take F 1 partial with respect to X 1 X 1
X 1 X 2 X 1 X 3 X 2 X 1 like there's
this whole cube of partial derivatives
here this is like a 4 dimensional cube
of partial derivatives these things are
called tensors they're really nasty and
it's better to forget them for now okay
but it's kind of interesting to think
about like try to generalize what we did
and imagine what the second Jacobian
like a second derivative of F with
respect to X is it's this really nasty
tensor looking thing it doesn't look
like a matrix right a matrix is a square
of numbers the cube of numbers okay so
the next example I want to do is pretty
quick and I just want to do another
example of linearizing dynamics with a
1d example that's a little bit more
straightforward okay so we're going to
do the logistic map ok so X dot equals f
of X equals x times some P max minus X
super simple now this is really not a
vector this is just a number X X is the
population of some species let's call it
humans okay so this is my population
this is the max population that my
planet can go my habitat can hold so
this is the max population based on
resources there's only so much corn we
can grow okay and this is called the
logistic equation
interestingly super simple equation
right it's like a quadratic
non-linearity it's one it's 1d if I
write down a numerical scheme to try to
integrate this solution forward in time
for lots of numerical schemes it's
completely chaotic and this actually
suggests that if I have like population
models where maybe people die at certain
parts of the year or are born at certain
parts of the year or like like rabbit
populations you can actually get chaotic
limit cycles of like really really large
populations then they crash and then
they go really really big and then they
crash so it's a really interesting
equation but for our purposes it has two
fixed points so X bar equals 0 and X bar
equals p max okay I can linearize this
about each of those fixed points so I
can say well DF DX is equal to P max
minus 2x just the derivative first
derivative and so we have kind of Delta
X dot equals P max minus 2 X bar times
Delta X this is my linearized equation
linearized about either of these two
fixed points this is exactly what we
wrote down before I'm just it's a 1d
example ok so let's just plug in the two
cases so case one is X bar equals zero
so what is this equal one X bar is zero
P max it's a big positive number right
maybe we can hold 10 billion people so
then DF DX equals P max this is my eigen
value if you will and it's positive so
it's unstable okay case two
is x-bar equals P max so now I plug that
in here and I get my eigen value as
minus P max all right I just plug in my
fixed point and I get P max minus 2 P
max minus P max so it's a minus big
number so it's really really stable at
this case so I can draw the phase
portrait or the XT diagram if you want
for this system okay so this is my
population X in time I have to fix
points I have 0 population and P max
these are my two fixed points ok so
which one of these is stable and which
one is unstable zero is unstable and P
maxes tables make sense zero is unstable
if I have like two people it's going to
exponentially grow until I saturate and
hit my max population or at least with
bunnies and P max is stable if I have a
few too few people it'll kind of the
population will increase and if I have
too many people those people will die
until it goes into equilibrium
so the equation looks essentially like
this in time kind of exponential
attraction on to P max an exponential
repulsion from 0 if I ever had negative
people I would get negative a bunch of
more people San which is bad so this is
a really simple example we can draw it
like we can interpret what the solution
means right this is like if you started
with a small population of people on an
island it would blow up until it hits
the carrying capacity of that island and
then it would saturate and if for some
reason you dropped two thousand more
people two thousand more people would
have to die okay okay so it's a simple
example okay so we know how to linearize
systems and so this is giving us a whole
kind of renewed interest in looking at X
dot equals ax because we can actually do
something useful with it
so if we have some interesting nonlinear
system we can linearize it around fixed
points and we can look at what those
fixed points do locally and we can start
getting an idea of what even the global
dynamics of my nonlinear differential
equation wool will look like and this is
actually what people do to plan
spacecraft missions and trajectories and
complex chaotic systems so for those of
you who are interested in control there
might be some fixed points that are
unstable but they're really good fixed
points that I want to be around like for
example if I have a flat plate with
fluid flow going past it then I have
some boundary layer and at some point I
get a transition into a turbulent
boundary layer and my drag explodes and
what I might want to do is try to
stabilize this unstable laminar boundary
layer right if we could get laminar flow
over all of our wings and trains and
cars and everything then we would spend
fifty billion dollars less a year in gas
so we want to stabilize laminar fluid
flows this happens to be an unstable
fixed point in a very high dimensional
differential equation that's nonlinear
so in the very very high dimensional
differential equation X dot equals f of
X where this is the Navy or stokes
equation and my X vector is my you know
vorticity or velocity at every single
point in the flow Billy and tall vector
laminar flow is an unstable fixed point
and with feedback control I can actually
stabilize it and I can maintain laminar
flow even though I have these nonlinear
dynamics because I'm in a vicinity of
that fixed point this is just an example
of what we might want to do with
stabilizing nonlinear systems or
analyzing analyzing them okay so the
example that I'm going to do now how
many of you are interested in fluid
flows okay few of you I'm very
interested in fluid flows we're actually
close to being able to do this on real
wings and trains and planes and
ours and I would say in the next 50
years we're going to have active control
to stabilize unstable fixed points and
fluid systems like it's going to happen
it's going to be awesome it's going to
save the world a lot of fuel okay so we
have some system dxdt equals ax times ax
hey so this is a case that we haven't
covered yet we started hinting at it but
if we look at the eigenvalues of this a
matrix so if we look at the eyes of a we
find that they're plus and minus 2i
okay that's a little bit strange because
this is a real-valued matrix this has
real valued solutions but it has complex
conjugate pair of eigen values so these
are on the imaginary axis of the complex
plane strange okay so how do I solve
this system once I know the eigenvalues
what's the next step if I want to know
what the full solution is I need to know
the eigenvectors okay so we're going to
see one for lambda 1 equals 2 I okay so
I have a minus 2i times c1 equals 0 and
a minus 2 times sorry a minus lambda I
so it's 2 times an imaginary number
times the identity matrix which there
was a different letter minus 2 I 2 minus
2 minus 2i times c1 just call this x and
y equals 0 0 ok so what has to be true
for this vector to multiply it by a
minus 2 lambda I and get zeros
okay so try x equals one and then we
have that y has to equal I so you can
kind of plug this in and verify that
this really is an eigenvector so so 1
and I is my C 1 ok let's try C 2 4 minus
2i
a minus minus is a plus 2i times the
identity C 2 has to equal 0 so now we
have 2 I 2 minus 2 2 I times X y equals
0 0 again I'm going to assume that X is
1 and if I plug in X is 1 then Y has to
equal minus I now ok this is weird my
eigenvectors are complex but i can still
write down the full solution I can write
down X at time T equals my matrix of
eigenvectors times e to the diagonal
matrix time times T inverse and what
we're going to find is that when we
stack these eigen vectors into T and we
write down this expression all of the
complex numbers are going to cancel out
which is good so you can take my word
that T inverse equals 1/2 times 1 1
minus I I okay I know this is boring
this is this is the second time I've
done this is only the first time you get
some time is this week so the point
though is that something magical happens
when you actually write this down and I
want us to actually see it to believe it
I think it's really very important that
when you actually write down the
solution all the imaginary parts cancel
and you get real numbers out ok so we're
going to say X at time T
equals big t e to the V diagonal T T
inverse times X at time 0 and I'm just
going to start writing this out so I
have I'm going to pull my 1/2 from my T
inverse out front so this is 1/2 times
ok my matrix of eigenvectors is 1 i 1
minus i eetu the diagonal t is e to the
2i t e to the minus 2i t and t inverse
is i already pulled out the 1/2 and now
i have 1 1 minus I I okay and this is of
course times X not okay so now we're
just going to multiply these two
matrices we're going to get okay you
still have 1/2 1 i minus i 1 times and i
have e to the 2i t and then i have e to
the minus 2i t and then again I have
minus i eetu the 2i t and i have i e to
the minus 2i t this is kind of a mess
you have to be very careful to get
everything right and finally when I
multiply this out I get this is times X
naught I get 1/2 e to the 2i t plus e to
the minus Qi T and then I get I times e
to the 2i t minus e to the minus 2i t
alright this times that okay then I get
I times minus e to the 2i t plus e to
the minus 2i t and finally I didn't mess
something up I get e to the 2i t
plus e to the minus 2i t okay this is
not as bad as it looks right it's not
great but it's not as bad as it looks
you can do all this multiplication
yeah there's complex numbers we know
what I times I is this is the full
solution okay but we still have e to the
2i T's and e to the minus 2i t use and
that's not great so how can I simplify
this kind of to the final level what's
the final level of simplification for
this right I can use that that formula
that we derived in like the second
lecture for e to the i-x all right so we
have this Euler's formula e to the I
theta equals coast data plus I sine
theta and let's just write down what
each of the minus I theta is so if I
plugged in a minus theta here what's
coasts of minus theta just cos theta and
what's comes what's sine of minus theta
minus sine theta so this is kind of good
right we have kind of the same real part
but we have opposite equal and opposite
imaginary part so this is starting to
look like these might be able to cancel
if we added these together okay that's
exactly what we're doing here so we have
e to the 2i t plus e to the minus 2i t
that's coast to t plus i sine 2t plus
cos 2t minus sine I to T and so that's
just two cosines of 2t perfect this term
cancelled out to something real and this
is the same term right here so the
second diagonal is also going to be 2
cosine of 2t ok what about this term
here what's what's minus e to the 2i t
plus e to the minus 2i T so minus this
guy plus this guy is minus 2i sine 2t so
minus
- I sign - T but remember we have an eye
out front that were multiplying so it's
minus 2i squared what's minus I squared
plus 1 I squared is minus 1 minus that
so this is plus 2 sine 2t and if you do
the same thing down here you find out
that you get a minus sign - t minus 2
sine 2t and my one half cancels
everything out but the bottom line is my
solution for let's write this as a
vector X naught and V naught my solution
to this differential equation right it
had complex eigenvalues plus and minus
2i but the solution for any real valued
initial position and any real valued
initial velocity are real right there
just sines and cosines of my position
and velocity and in fact we find that my
position and my velocity are out of
phase by PI over 2 or 90 degrees ok so
in the example we did earlier where we
took the spring mass system right with
no damping we had a complex conjugate
pair of eigen values plus and minus I
Omega and when we pulled this mass back
and let it go it just oscillated forever
and remember as the position is
oscillating back and forth like a cosine
the velocity is oscillating back and
forth like a sine so it's out of phase
and that's exactly what we see here we
just start with some X naught and V
naught as 0 we have our final position
as coasts and our final velocity is
minus sine so they're out of phase with
each other and that's a really nice
interpretation for what it means when we
have complex eigenvalues ok so we can
have complex eigenvalues in a system
that has that's real valued and that
just might that means that some of my
states are out of phase with each other
they're doing cosines and sines out of
phase with each other that's exactly
what my position and velocity are doing
okay so for the last thing I'm just
going to draw the face portrait because
it's nice to see what this looks like
and we're going to use it next time okay
this matrix also for those of you who
recognize that this is a rotation matrix
this takes my initial X naught and V
naught and it rotates it by 2 T so as
time progresses my initial vector of
position and velocity is just rotating
but it's radius is not changing I mean
you can try a vector like plug in a
vector X naught V not multiply it by
this matrix and you'll see that it
rotates that vector so if this is X and
V and this is my you know X naught V
naught my solution just stays on these
circles forever
these concentric circles okay so that's
what the phase portrait looks like for
this system with complex conjugate pairs
of eigenvalues and it's called a center
because it looks like a bull's-eye
so I guess the point here is we can do
all of this math with complex numbers it
doesn't matter at all you can have
complex valued lambdas complex valued
eigenvectors and you can still get
solutions using the formula that we
derived before this formula and these
systems are neutrally stable if I add
the tiniest bit of damping to this
equation so I have a little minus 1 or
minus 0.1 here then my Center becomes a
spiral sink you'll find that my
eigenvalues will look like you know
minus something plus or minus 2i
something like that so it'll be stable
and oscillatory if I add a little
negative damping so this thing is kind
of going unstable then I'll get a
unstable spiral it'll kind of blow up
and oscillate as it does it kind of
oscillate in sines and cosines and so
this gets back to Ben's question of what
happens when I have a non-linearity
well these eigenvalues could go a little
bit unstable or a little bit stable and
that's a tricky thing to to analyze it's
actually pretty pretty complicated so
what it means to have like a negative
real part and an oscillation means that
I have this exponentially decaying
envelope e to the minus T and my
solution is oscillating as its decaying
right if I plotted X with respect to
time that's exactly what it would look
like is this decaying oscillation okay
so I want you to play around with these
things okay this is like this is not a
whole class of dynamical systems I can't
like we could spend a whole week looking
at these types of systems it's very very
interesting try some of these out plot
them in MATLAB play around with adding
damping and see what the eigenvalues do
see what the phase portraits do and
convince yourself that this is really
what's happening I mean in MATLAB you
can literally do
od e45 simulation and then plot the you
know the X column of the output against
the V column of the output and you'll
get this phase portrait okay so in the
next class what we're going to do is
combine all of these ideas we're going
to take nonlinear systems from physics
from F equals MA we're going to identify
the fixed points and we're going to use
these linearizations to start getting a
global view of what the dynamics of
systems look like for nonlinear systems
extremely useful this will allow us to
figure out where spacecraft and
asteroids go among many many many other
things okay
that's all for today I'll see you on
Friday thank you
to